seit heute sie wissen das ist großer spd
parteitag in berlin
und dass ich das noch erleben darf meine
damen und herren nach über 150 jahren
traut sich die gute alte spd zum ersten
mal eine richtige revolution
[Musik]
ich höre gerade doch nicht ja ja ja
revolution fällt aus sorry der parteitag
wird gar nicht über ein großer aus
abstimmen weil ja nachher kommt da noch
was raus was man gar nicht will
hey hey aber immerhin die basis der
partei hat einfach mal zwei totale
underdog zur vorsitzenden gewählt die
hier ja saskia esken und norbert walter
borjans doppelnamen norbert walter
borjans gegen den ausdrücklichen willen
der kompletten spd prominenz das schon
revolution revolution das hier war der
moment ihres überraschenden sieges und
am entspannten lächeln von preston
erkennen wir hier wird dir klar
ach du scheiße ich bin spd chefin
mein leben ist vorbei aber der erfolg
des neuen duos heute vom parteitag
übrigens bestätigt ist natürlich auch
eine müssen wir sozusagen furchtbare
klatsche für vizekanzler olaf scholz
ich glaube das hat wirklich wehgetan
habe meiner finanzminister ist ein
bisschen so als wenn du real madrid bist
und verliert gegen den sv wetten dass
ist das ist hart wobei gehört auch zu
weit wobei das ja kein fairer wettstreit
war die komplette spd prominenz hatte
sich fürs team scholz keilwitz
ausgesprochen öffentlich um die
außenseiter zu verhindern wurde da ja
teilweise mit absurden methoden
gearbeitet jeder generalsekretär redet
und steht ganz zufällig suchen und dass
die herausforderer optimal zur geltung
kommen jaja glückwunsch spd die zwei
hier das kommt davon vor allem liebe
spd-führung wenn man seine arme basis
jahre lang von einer grob in die nächste
labert dann kommt sowas jetzt sie
wirklich schlechte nachricht
walter-borjans und essen sind
möglicherweise auch er luftnummern
ja ich wollte bis zu ende hören da ist
ja so erst hieß es der koalitionsvertrag
wird nachverhandelt mit der union oder
wir gehen raus aus der gruppe j ist nur
noch von gesprächen mit der union die
rede ohne echten zeitdruck das ist jetzt
nur dass ein bisschen zu hart
das ist zu hart sind vor allem frau
ascon hat heute eine engagierte rede
gehalten auf dem parteitag sogar mit
einem schuss sitzen poesie hört die
signale die neue zeit sie ruft mir gehen
nach formel wir geben nicht mehr und wir
blicken auch nicht mehr zurück wir gehen
nach vorne in die neue insight ich danke
euch ja entschuldigung ich will nicht
klugscheißern aber wir gehen alle
ständig in eine neue zeit
das ist überhaupt keine leistung jetzt
quasi immer wieder zusammen in der
neuzeit gegangen ist egal ich kenne das
lied ihre vorschläge die vorschläge der
beiden sind ja vernünftig 12 euro
mindestlohn und eine große
investitionsoffensive letzteres fordern
ja auch fordern ja auch gewerkschaften
und industrie gemeinsam wird nur halt
nicht kommen mit der union und das
wissen auch norbert und saskia wie
heißen noch norbert und saskia oder dann
brauchen wir eine andere konsequenz
und ich meine mit walter und mit sk
kriegen wir das hin
absolut das war
ja
mein reden wir kriegen das hin mit
walter und sk die eigentlichen arbeit
und saskia heißen sie werden weiter
regieren die sozen und sie werden es uns
weiter als opfergang verkaufen selbst
juso-chef kühnert der doch eigentlich
das volk der sozen aus der groko führen
wollte wir erinnern uns ja
selbst er hier warnt plötzlich vor einem
übereilten groko aus lasst euch mal
ruhig zeit ihr seid ihr erst bei 14
prozent
da ist noch jede menge luft nach unten
nein wirklich nicht hetzen und falls sie
sich fragen wie haben er und seine jusos
es eigentlich geschafft diese
vorsitzendenwahl vom letzten wochenende
zu entscheiden
das liegt daran dass man da per
mausklick abstimmen konnte
am 30 november wurde eine wahl
entschieden durch eine winzige
minderheit die keiner auf dem zettel
hatte junge menschen in der spd
angeführt von einem ein meter 30 großen
guru mexikaner auf wenn sie können etwas
das alte menschen nicht können
einen computer bedienen ich stimme für
olaf scholz spd
das fax gerät unter den parteien
ich habe viele junge leute
der große teen lässt die idee vom
schnellen gruppe aus verschwinden ja
extra für ihn für kevin haben sie heute
einen neuen vorstandsposten geschaffen
in der spd damit der junge endlich von
der straße sitzen so oder so so oder so
walter-borjans und essen haben
selbstverständlich eine chance verdient
allerdings gibt es da ein problemchen
dass der cdu-mann strobl so
zusammenfasst und ganz die wahrheit zu
sagen habe ich erst vor einigen wochen
einigen wenigen monaten ihren namen zum
ersten mal gehört und ich gebe ganz
offen zu dass ich erstmal dem google
nachschauen musste um welche kollegen es
sich eigentlich handelt indem google
stand hast ja herr strobl hat seinen
google aus dem bücherregal geholt und
darin gelesen
die sind dass sie kenne ich gar nicht so
wir schauen mal rüber ins
willy-brandt-haus dort leitet matthias
matschke eine marketing task force die
walter borjans und essen jetzt pushen
soll damit jemals bekannter werden in
der bevölkerung herrsche wünscht man
aber auch kein ach quatsch
ein guter pr man kann jeden groß machen
ich hab martin schulz dahin gebracht wo
er heute ist also in würselen
dagegen ist das jedoch ein mit piece of
cake ich guck die bloß an dieser beiden
charisma raketen und die ideen sprudeln
nur so saskia und norbert
leute was ist denn los das ist ein
brainstorming ich brauche den was fällt
euch spontan ein zusatz b und norbert
kommen das erste was durch den kopf
kommt das eine ist eine frau ja danke
wolfgang das eine ist eine frau das weiß
ich auch mit reißt euch mal zusammen die
beiden sind jetzt unsere vorsitzenden
wahrscheinlich für mehrere wochen
wir haben bisher nur scheiß plakate
sowas hier
saskia und norbert sie haben halt
gewonnen und nicht toll aber sie hätten
mal die anderen kandidaten sehen soll
damit kann ich nicht arbeiten wir müssen
positiv denken der norbert und die
dingsbums sind ein power couple wie
habeck und berbalk nur halt ohne
eigenschaften
ich sage unter weiter und unsere sabine
die müssen sich überhaupt nicht
verstecken auch nicht vor ihren
vorgängern wie groß sind die fußstapfen
in die sie da reingehen zunächst mal
sind wir zu zweit wir unsere schuhgrößen
zusammenbrechenden kommt da ganz schön
was zusammen
so nämlich lovato hat schuhgröße 38 sie
hat 46 sind zusammen 84 pingo so große
quanten hat nicht mal sigmar gabriel
entschuldigung er hat mit seinen
steuersünder-cds den staat damals sieben
milliarden eingebracht und sie ist eine
anerkannte digital experten recht das
reicht mir direkt auf manchmal ich sehe
hier gerade noch was geht es bei google
novo hatte als finanzminister von nrw
drei verfassungswidrig überschuldete
haushalte
der ist träger des bodys becker
insolvenz ordens am band und sagt ja war
mal vize chefin des landeselternbeirats
baden württemberg von wegen die an noch
nie eine wahl gewonnen ja hier hermann
spiel werden sehen mit einem von den
beiden auch ins kanzlerin gehen ein
kanzler von der spd
was für drogen ich darf ja leider noch
nichts konkretes verraten aber uns ist
gerade ein spektakulärer transfer
geglückt
nächstes jahr kommt jemand neu ins team
der wirklich sozialdemokratische politik
war
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und das beste ist das beste ist diese
person hat 20 21 garantiert zeit mehr
sage ich nicht wie gesagt alles noch
streng geheim interessierte kein
matthias matschke meine damen und herren
michael beschreibt auf facebook wilke du
bist der letzte arsch nur große fresse
ich möchte ich mal sehen wenn es hart
auf hart kommt dann schaust du dir in
die hose warte ab ein sprichwort sagt
man trifft sich immer zweimal im leben
mach weiter so mit einer großen fresse
wie können warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 im zweiten oder hier
auf youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren